- Good morning Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs are going
to solve all of the
world's major problems.
So, to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn how to commit.
Over to you Vince Lombardi.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I've been around high
performance people all my life.
And really for my own
growth, my own development,
I've made it my mission, my
purpose, to study these people.
People of all walks of life.
People of military. People in government.
Word class athletes. Great coaches.
People of the private
sector, such as a lot of you.
And I've studied them with a thought.
What do they do when
they're at their best?
It's my intention this evening
to hold up for you a mirror.
A mirror that you can look into
and examine for yourself the breadth
and the depth of your
goals, and the commitment,
and the discipline, and
the perseverance you bring
to the pursuit of those goals.
It's my intention this evening
to curate within you a little dissidence,
a little disharmony, a
little dissatisfaction,
which is the essence of motivation.
So of the balance of the evening you begin
to ask yourself some hard questions.
And maybe you'll be
satisfied with the answers,
and maybe you won't.
I'm not going to tell you
anything you don't already know.
Just thought that maybe I'd present it
to you a little differently.
Perhaps in a manner that you
haven't seen or heard before.
Now you may sit there and say,
"Well, Vince. Nothing new. Come on.
Not the same old, same old.
Not the same old motivational stuff
where every time we come
to a meeting like this."
Well, let me ask you a question.
How many diets does it take to get down
to the weight you'd like to be at?
Just one. The one you stick with.
How many times you have
to reorganize your office,
your desk, your approach to
your business, your profession,
your career before you begin to see some
of the results you'd like to see?
Just one. The one you
commit to and stick with.
And how many personal growth programs
do you have to take on before you begin
to see some of the changes
in your personal life you'd
like to see? Just one.
The one you commit to and
discipline yourself to stick with.
- Most people don't get the
success that they're looking for
because they don't
commit to doing the work.
Again, if you look at any
major successful person
that you look up to in any field,
the people who are your role models,
the people you want to emulate,
the people you want to be like.
They got there because
they committed to the plan.
They took action every
single day on that plan.
Too many people get started on one thing,
and they lose interest in
it, or it starts to get hard,
and so they jump to another thing,
and they jump to another thing,
and they jump to another thing.
And because they don't
take consistent action,
because they don't
commit fully to the plan,
then they don't have the
success that they want to have.
Because anything that is worth
doing is going to get hard.
Starting a business is really hard.
Losing weight is hard.
Putting on muscle is hard.
All the important things that
you want to go after and do,
at some point, is going to get hard.
And what most people do,
as soon as it gets hard,
is they quit and they go look
for a shortcut down another path,
because that path is
going to be way easier
than what you're doing right now.
As soon as that path gets
hard, you jump to another path,
which is also, you think
is going to be easier,
but as soon as it gets hard, you stop.
And that's what most
people do with businesses.
They start a business. It gets hard.
They go do something else. It gets hard.
They go do something else.
It's what they do with diets.
They start a diet. It gets too hard.
That didn't work. They gave it two days.
It didn't work. They gave it a week.
It didn't work. They quit and
they go do something else.
It doesn't matter which diet you stick to.
For the business, as long as
you're passionate about it.
The one that's going to work is the one
that you commit to and take
daily consistent action on.
If I look at my YouTube
channel, it started to explode
and really grow when I
committed to it more fully.
At the start, I just had a
channel, I just saved the name.
I was posting a couple videos,
answering some questions,
but it wasn't until I
took it consistently,
when I said, "Okay, I'm
going to do regular videos
from once a week, to once a day,
to twice a day, to three times a day."
Go back on my channel,
and that's when you see the
growth starts to happen.
And that's going to happen
in every area of your life.
In every business decision.
In every personal decision.
When you commit to following through,
and you take consistent action on it,
that's when you start to see results.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what are you afraid to commit to?
In your business, or in your life.
What's almost there, but you're afraid
to take that final step
and go all in and commit.
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Xavier Monty
from hellotalent.com.
Xavier, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, 'Your One Word.'
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I looked at the odds, you know,
like how am I even going to
break in to this business, right.
All the good parts, you know.
As an unknown actor, to get a great role,
every other actor has
to pass on it, right.
Every other actor has to pass on it.
And then it gets opened up to you
and thousands of other
people like you, right,
and you all go.
And there are a few parts.
Like I was looking at a big part
when I was younger, was Primal Fear.
Remember that movie with Richard Gere?
And Edward Norton got the part.
- [Interviewer] After everyone passed.
- Yeah. So that part became
open, every young actor knew it.
I mean we went, I paid
with money I did not have
to take dialect lessons.
Hired a dialect coach because the kid was,
his alter ego was from Kentucky,
and he was from somewhere else,
and I'd never been to Kentucky.
We knew that that was it.
That was going to launch somebody.
There just weren't opportunities.
And so Courage Under Fire was one
of those roles that was small.
It was really only, it was two scenes.
I had two scenes with Denzel.
And then the rest of
it was, I'm the medic.
Tim Guinee, an actor who I love,
who's in Promised Land, actually,
is like bleeding out on my lap.
For six weeks we're in El Paso,
and he's moaning, and
I'm just sitting there,
and I'm like, "I don't think
the camera's on us man."
(laughing)
It was a really thankless
job for both of us
except for those two scenes
that I had with Denzel.
So I had two days of work on that movie,
and so I went, well, what do I do?
It's told in flashback, so let me see.
How can I change myself?
What can I do?
The guy's supposed to have
become a heroine addict.
Okay, well, so what do I do
to make that seem like it happened?
And the only thing I
could come up with was
to lose as much weight as I could,
and then put it back on as fast as I could
to go do the flashback stuff.
And so that's what I did.
- I heard that wasn't
good for your health.
Like your doctor was surprised.
- No it was terrible.
It was bad because I didn't, I asked them
for a nutritionist, which
was probably $1500 or $2500,
and they said no.
I don't think they, in their defense,
I don't think they really
knew what I was going to do.
They probably have requests
like this all the time,
and they think they're vanity requests,
but it was a serious request
and they turned it down.
And so I went to a friend.
We had a friend. We knew a guy--
(laughing)
who was also, he was Austrian.
I mean, funnily enough, he was Austrian
and he was trying to be an actor
but he literally, because he was Austrian,
he had Arnold's accent and
he was a former bodybuilder.
So he was really aiming
at a small bullseye,
(laughing)
because his spot was
really taken by somebody.
But he put me on his program
that he would do for bodybuilding shows.
But they would do that
program three weeks out.
They would do this really
kind of reckless thing,
and so those guys walk on stage
and you could push, they look strong,
but you could knock them over.
They're really suffering at that point.
To kind of leach every
bit of everything out
so that the veins and the muscles pop out.
So I did it for like three
and a half or four months,
which was just too much, too much.
But at the same time, it worked.
It worked, and when I got The
Rainmaker a year or so later,
Coppola said that he'd
seen Courage Under Fire,
and that that made a big difference.
And funnily enough it
was Edward Norton and I
who were going against
each other again for that,
and the Courage Under Fire
pushed me over the edge.
And when I met Spielberg
later, and he looked at me,
and he said, "What?"
And I'd put myself on tape
for Saving Private Ryan.
I never heard anything.
I don't think the tape every got to him.
The casting director maybe
looked at it and chucked it.
So I thought he'd seen it.
And he said, "What do I know you from?"
And I said, "I put myself
on tape for your movie."
He goes, "Nah, I didn't see any tape."
He goes, "What movies have you been in?"
I said, "I was in a movie
called Courage Under Fire."
And he goes, "You know I turned to my wife
when I saw that movie and said
that's the exact guy I
want for Private Ryan.
I just wish he wasn't so skinny."
(laughter)
- I feel like I read a
interview at the time
that said you couldn't
even kiss your girlfriend
because you could taste
potato chips on her lips.
- The oil from them, yeah.
People who have those disorders, I got it.
I totally understood it.
I just told myself I can't allow anything,
there's no, no compromising.
None, because the second
you open that door,
it's a slippery slope.
I wanted to look back on it
and go, "I did absolutely
everything I could."
- I had been working my whole life,
and what I didn't understand
by being determined to taste something,
by being committed to it.
And what commitment is,
commitment is staying true to
what you said you were going to do long
after the mood that you
have said it in has left.
You see, people think
commitment is saying,
"Yes, I'll do it on the
days when it feel good."
But I have been committed to everything
that I have ever started in my life,
and I never stopped, and I never quitted.
And so by being committed to
everything that I started,
I finished it. It built
the certain type of spirit.
It built the certain type of mentality.
It built the certain type of individual.
And so now I couldn't
quit even if I wanted to.
I couldn't lay in the
bed even if I wanted to.
I couldn't stop even if I wanted to.
I have too much sweat equity in my life,
in everything that I was doing.
Because I understood my
existence wasn't about me.
I went from me to we a long time ago.
I understood the process is
more important than the product.
It wasn't about the outcome for me.
Whether I made it to the NFL or not,
that was inconsequential
in God's plan for my life.
But I was going to fall
in love with that process,
because I understood by falling
it was going to turn me into a machine.